dear colleagues today we have
the pleasure of welcoming among us
nicolas schmit the new
european commissioner in charge of employment and
social rights
this commissioner first of all i
would like to congratulate you on your
appointment and thank you for
joining us  during the first days
of your mandate, which are also the
last of another,
your portfolio occupies an
important place on the European agenda
because social rights are a
fundamental pillar of a union closer to
its citizens
it is the  this is why since
the adoption of the European Pillar of Social Rights
we have been asking for a detailed action plan
concerning its implementation and the
President is making hatred we have made the
promise in her
political guidelines for the next European Commission
this plan of  action will have to be accompanied by the
necessary funding, in particular
through the European social fund, plus
this is what we are asking for in our
a  alliance for cohesion in favor
of a strong cohesion policy in
this context the european committee of the
regions propose to complete the
social scoreboard which makes it possible
to examine the implementation of the pillar
with a regional dimension in order to
measure the extent  social challenges in
europe is free to respond to them
it is necessary not only
to focus on national indicators
but also to take into
account the local and regional level
a few months ago we produced
such a regional dashboard which
based on
existing eurostat tu regional indicators and we
hope to continue to work on them in
close collaboration with the new
commission a challenge that will certainly occupy us in
the coming years
concerns the future of work
technological developments already in the process
of significant changes
by jeopardizing certain professions and
by creating new forms
of employment, the structures pr  workers
are in the process of transformation and
digital platform workers
are a good example of
how the digital age offers new
employment opportunities while creating
new inequalities and regulatory challenges
after our debate on  'today new
3 an opinion on work on
digital platforms regulatory issues
at local and
regional level
it highlights the need to establish a
comprehensive regulatory framework that
guarantees the social rights and
protection of workers of
digital platforms
the  objective is to put
the economy of
digital platforms and the so-called
traditional economy on an equal footing with the same rights and
obligations
the commissioner we really look forward
to working with you on these
issues and we wish and we
wish you a world with  crowned with
success it is with great pleasure that I
now wish you the floor for  r
you,
Mr. President, dear members of the
Committee of the Regions,
Mr. President, allow
me first of all to thank you for this
invitation and to congratulate you,
I know that you will soon be leaving
this term of office as President and I would
really like to pay tribute to you for the
work  what you accomplished
during this mandate, you not
only gave visibility to the Committee of the
Regions,
but above all you also
emphasized the important role that this
Committee plays in promoting the
European idea and above all in  concrete action
by europe in the
territories i would also like to
express my best wishes for the 25th
anniversary of your committee i
was in the
maastricht negotiations when the idea of ​​a committee of the
regions emerged and i believe that  it was
an excellent idea since europe
is first of all the regions the cities the
regional cultures
it is all this that shaped our
continent and gave birth to
the European idea
so I wish you for the future
the same the same energy the same desire
to contribute to the European project since
the European project is
taking shape it is taking shape in the
territories indeed the new
commission took office a
few years ago  days and therefore you are in
a way my first
interlocutors and I was responsible in
this commission
for both employment and social rights
I am very proud to bear
this title commissioner for employment
and employment  it is something that
is very close to your heart and social rights
it is the first time moreover that a
social rights commissioner who
clearly refers to the pillars of the
pillar of social rights and who shows
the direction and the direction  it is the
strengthening of social europe, as
the president on the ground has said is supported and forcefully expressed
in order to go
yen on several occasions and
in particular in her speech before the
european parliament  éen
this commission has before it two
major deadlines with major issues
you listened earlier to the vice
president france team oman this puppy the
ecological transition on the green deal
which will be a little the green thread I would say of
this term of office and which is  very
ambitious since we
actually want to transform europe into a
continent in a union that respects
the environment and and in order to move forward
in the fight against
climate change, but we will only succeed in this
transition if it is socially
fair, so the  The fight against
climate change and the commitment
to a social Europe go hand in hand
and one will not succeed without the other,
so the second major aspect is
economic transitions and in particular the
major technological transitions
and the response to these transitions
technological and economic,
it is also, among other things, the pillar of
social rights which was put in place
under the president of the presiding commission.
dée by jean claude juncker i must
say that this commission and jean claude
juncker a compatriot bequeathed us a
formidable instrument which we must
now use to make this
europe more social and closer to the
citizens digitization and you go take
care of it where i  I have watched the life you
have prepared will shape both our
industries our services work but
also our regions our cities our
public services
it will profoundly change the way of
working
the way of communicating it will
also change globalization both in
bringing a certain number of regions out
of relative isolation it will
allow them to be opened up, even the
outermost regions
it is therefore a new chance will of
course also create new
competition since the platforms
are not national are not
European they are global  it
will also make it possible to relocate a certain
number of activities which have left our
regions  on our cities and who have
left europe so both
tremendous opportunities but also
transformations which we have to
prepare for and which we have to prepare and we
have to prepare them by investing a
lot I believe that investing
in the future  investment in both
digital infrastructure networks networks capital in
particular capital for you for your
regions for your cities because if
you don't have your phone if
your computer isn't working,
you're disconnected from  a time when it
is absolutely necessary to be connected investing
also in men and women,
i.e. investing
in skills is crucial and we
will succeed in this transformation
both climatic, environmental and
digital only if we invest and
if we invest  massively
in skills and it's also a
chance it's a chance in particular for
the more peripheral regions since
perhaps  e we are going to be able to bring
the periphery closer to the center and reduce these
gaps which exist within europe
and have a
much stronger instrument of economic and social cohesion
moreover i i recall this idea of
ericsson forsman belgium which shows
that the villages  the isolated villages where
there are a lot of discs satisfaction a
lot of concern in
rural areas
today that they can find a
new place in this europe which
joins the economy of the 21st century
for me the skills it is at the heart
of  this revolution
therefore investment in skills
is crucial and investment in
skills is also done in the
territories is done in the cities is
done in the schools is done in the
institutions that must be created that must be created
closer and citizen so that
they effectively acquire the
skills necessary to
master new technologies
effectively have jobs of  future
and jobs 2
quality of the future i am also thinking
of youth unemployment
president van der leyen has asked me
to review strengthen the youth guarantee
you know the drama the
tragedy of unemployed young people
you personally often know
in  cities young people in
difficult neighborhoods and who have no
social perspective whatsoever but a
spectrum yves of jobs it is these
young people who should be addressed
it is with you that europe  must
go find them and give them
a real perspective and it is in this
respect that we are going to work on
this youth guarantee which has been
a great success but which needs to be
improved further strengthened I entirely
welcome what  the european parliament has
voted an extension of the budget to fight
against youth unemployment of crosses
around 400 million that must
actually be used to get these
young people out of distress and despair
since europe is getting stronger
if young people are regaining confidence and are
regaining are regaining hope,
we have now entered into
difficult negotiations on the
financial framework and in this context it
is in any case a question of not depriving the
European social fund of the
necessary resources since it  is the
social fund which effectively enables us at
European level to carry out a certain
number of social policies in the
regions in the towns and in
particular to address the most vulnerable and
those who need it the most, and in
this context this fund which will  be created
over time to fight against
climate change, which you have
surely mentioned, my colleague
vice-president timmons,
the just transition fund it will be an
important instrument alongside other
instruments, in particular also the fund
against globalization where the
fund  adjustment to globalization
I would also like to say a few words on
the social economy a few days ago
the president  founding la hyène
entrusted me with the mission of implementing an
action plan for the social economy,
I welcome this,
I believe that the social economy is the
one that is also very attached to the
territory,
it is often  a response to unemployment
unemployment of the most vulnerable to unemployment, in
particular people who are often excluded
from the labor market, and therefore with you
and your committee,
I am going to work on this action plan
so that this
social economy, which represents millions
of jobs, is effectively  which represents nearly 10% of
European gdp' be further strengthened
and effectively allow us
to combine economic convergence on the one
hand and social convergence on the other
the two are inseparably linked to the word
on wages yes we are going to
work on a framework  pious for a
minimum wage in europe since
wage convergence is a
central element of social convergence but
is also an important element of
economic and social cohesion
What we are seeing today is
that regions are depopulated because
the most qualified, most dynamic young people are
leaving because they
see no future there because they see
that their living conditions are too
difficult
so we need a cane
alignment of
salary convergence in europe on the platforms
I have already talked about it a little believe that the
principle is regardless of the status
of the worker whether he is self
-employed 1/2  or semi-independent any worker,
whatever his status, must have
rights,
that's the spirit of the pillar of
social rights, must have rights to
social protection, must have the right
to collective bargaining, in order to also have
the right to
fair and just working conditions
my last point is the fight
against poverty
we have brought small successes
in this fight against poverty
when I read that the
poverty rate has indeed gone from 25% to 22  %
we can be happy about it but we
cannot stop there
so when we know that there are 110
million poor people in europe or people
threatened by the risk of poverty
we have an enormous task ahead of us
and the fight against poverty
it is first of all the fight against the causes
of poverty it is the fight for
greater
equality and moreover the president
I quote her once again to
plead a lot for equality a union
of equality in  all the senses and the fight
against poverty is first of all a
fight for more equality for
more equity in europe
we have, as one of the major projects
in this context of the fight against
poverty, a guarantee for the  childhood
because poor children come
from poor families but worse still
reproduce poverty since they
will often unfortunately generally become
adults poor
herons of poor families
so it is the worst exclusion it is
the worst discrimination  tions therefore to
attack there to vote by the children
I believe it is extremely important to
give to each European child of the
rights of the rights to a school of the rights
to a given education the rights to
a
to medical care has and it is almost
shameful to  see it said
a decent meal every day is
shameful when you know that there are
deprived
children thousands of millions of children in
europe who do not have this right there and therefore
we are going to work on this
guarantee for the  childhood and there again I
believe that your committee and those who
make it up must help us because
the fight for against there to vote for
children it is not done in Brussels
it is done in the cities it is
done in the regions it is done  even
in the neighborhoods
so we need this
local action to actually succeed in this
project is a last word on
housing because housing is
often at the very heart of social exclusion
and poverty
Of course, I know that Europe does not have
great skills in
housing,
but we must also take a look
at this aspect. We should perhaps
focus more on the promotion
of housing on water sanitation.
housing and france timmons
has surely talked about it there are millions
or hundreds of thousands of
homeless people in europe they are
also excluded from the job market and we do
n't get someone back for the job market
if they are  does not first of all have housing so
we must in this fight against
poverty also integrate a policy
of course which will not be carried out at
European level which will have to be rolled
out at national and regional level
a housing policy I said we
want equality in every way
for europe we want a union
of equality our course is an economy
at the service of all at the service of
all citizens
an economy that works for the
people i believe that in there
the
crucial social the social is very important
so I read with great interest
the proposals of the european committee of the
regions to renew the
european union from the ground
working together to bring
the european union closer to its citizens it is
a  proposal which I accept very
willingly I share your idea of
active subsidiarity, i.e.
including cities including regions both the
decision-making process of
the union and we will only have success in
its various  programs that I
mentioned only if we manage to
get them to take root in the
territories and in the regions and therefore
I am delighted to put into practice
this subtle active subsidiarity to
put it into practice with you with the aim
of strengthening the  social dimension of
the union and thus to strengthen
economic and social cohesion
within the union for a union closer to
the citizens closer to the territories
a more united union  thank you thank you
thank you very much, commissioner,
the ten or so subjects that you
have addressed are all at the very
heart of the activities of the european committee
of the regions is what you have said
makes us very very positive and full
of hope for the work that  we
will be able to accomplish in the months and
years to come
forgiveness during the months and years to
come they interest is also shown by
the number of speakers we
now have 18 speakers but
the speaker will be respected very
strictly
and without delay I would like to ask
Mr. Brych to start the debate
I had spoken about it as it is a question of
DIY in which must stick to the bar
tosic suffer all the phone calls
to the stumps to the tax nor cows breakdown
clerk wise identifies cavaou opinion
beard of the gender  problem of something else
we take is to change everything
nadja kamer nadia styger infrastructures
it from identification modest problem
robotnik base of time i  n anatolia
star legends economist paul czm with
luciana aura while they boost
center just that his problem is the
mines a brave man never denies his beautiful
daughter you won't go jean promised calm
and nicely game metroid other m in rave
parties  platform sat enthroned like here in the country
what exists in injectors reading and
next in the agreements good image
at madame michelle wie cute
political groups who is he talking about raymond
archer staffelli shmona spots luck in the
competitions teachers in a
structure elsewhere luck in the  thugs you are led
by jean but never be creativ nîmes alès
group who are the starlish archers
but I have no nurseries the buyer games
mac os x 100 m with two sèvres in geneva
m avesnes stacking toyota too divisive
at the foot when you  are saved all the
rhythmic night jurists just recently
that luciana bardot never poor of will
cost you his albums at
unequal levels works at valves where the
hotel room of a jacket peña that he
will hide chipset in the village
ja i live at jive w
nice no i'm holding nagel
valve game which couples to digest but i
do everything me from claude j - j lo jay
cabbage kung fu gomis belonged to the
platforms and from his fervent
statistics he  going to change
instant greenwood van de bunt chalus venice
good weather bad weather that reigns in
this market it is an opinion of judo
dear life daubresse fifteen years of
tactics very young africa what my mind
problem observers hope
they internet platform with  all the
other fashionable young people like
here the lifestyle of this patch dragage
claude jouve replied I'm
leaving but our sign accor boul'mich
sauviac with the voices of the regional much
better than me I live store
attractive engine of sparta  your name
shania skills there will be this flight which
had only one string m lojie particular
section i live i had to go
there besides lusignan vienna provided by
chi minh themed i ve  ux i'm going to
eat you bout alain gignac is not
infected come from a badge in the
national colors via the addition of
household savings among our young people to the minister
i'm going to come back at 8 a.m. and 9 a.m. a young
rich couple but it's  is an
opinion proof of mind isn't it giles
just need i use for james
need all chance income forwards
must incidentally second star china
prevail mercilessly much the word
is now our colleague
karjalainen
to us  it should also be indicated to the
secretariat so it is madam a stream
who speaks in place of madam because there are
leymen who were registered
please 4 6 4 lee smith the
world awards and an arena mode where
the  intelligence machine learning and
autonomous system of this chance for
work and when we leave each employee in
october and came from these rentals
estimates klaus
dentist or intelligent algorithm
intelligence china as one of the
ten dead m markets innovation this year
comp  makes the 6 beds commission document
of 90 double beds
thank you very much and now the floor for
our colleague is over
thank you very much the floor is now
for our colleague a piano his strums his
previous and senior police station
signori colleagues and we would have allowed some
to intervene as  an important cause
and named the group here at voreppe
reloading the theme is under discussion
but he places european leaders
sochaux punto against 1.30 dollar
tennis yonnais soulacais and de hervé on
the promotion and derby line walks early
in life talbot rotivel familia
through on some of our
technologies religion but tiring
date objective bobigny data fatigue
still dinars what's the matter the euro
quickly to the borat goes there this family chalet
richir used at the same time give
flexibility and mode oa regala family
and des  armbands 1 second on the piano
respects richness for
fundamental consent to color that the
names of the po  ker 40 years old whose
family there created surgery ends t
is own there are so-called
regional next-generation freighters or six
other minority regions guardi
when one traditional wood nazi leonida
and europeans
use and his grave untouched at the islands
paternity leave hachey john perry
padre family and for
the refinery strikers have bet and gravitas
sincerity in their interests of his
sudden back to share your tears and roses
and and demographic favorites and the
reduction in the number of sites and
objectively the  ostriconi of our
interests nor Tunisian father and out of selfishness
moment is normal and it's too much to say no
to say our bar and a pole of
equity and volunteers is
likely that you to conceive eventually
is a few things to learn
[Music  ]
thank you very much and I would like to point out that
now the list of speakers is
closed because otherwise we will
never be able to respect the time the
next novateu  r it is our colleague
dimitrov bul pa this title allows the
machines by matic august and for five
years by the police on tuesday that it will be necessary to
form a government that is
powerfully iris who has what
form and cinema at the break  because
I was told that it does not mean that we are
at our best but they all live only if my
races
after effects in heaven before made in
africa my fault of kita who love me and
that is what  who is these inch metals and
admit bisauta problem did he summarize
our six platform s is voted which
ergonomics and I would remain on the
4 poles area graphic materials
quickly able elima and as
they wet kenya
african moyer who blackened cake  in
the draw then by another
annex episode between bordeaux and idrissa gracias
by issa and victor morning is this not
what can happen
san antonio texas at the start but
platform and will prepare for the
problem but yours accident
but these metaphors or  do you know  ou well
it's us ourselves what was done six
stained glass windows 6 2 6 1 6 2 km
yama ermotti is not because if they
left on yahoo orange
realize become a carnon photographer he
would come cammas to hide topic  is
preferred to dock it's not the police
got me biko totti and khemis to motorcycles
kisses but its flagship products
website cases come from both of
course end my family is here
eolys about fesman by four and
ciara methods  here on radar honey smacks
insp at the advanced acquired economy at 10 mg
and it's difficult for me who savings
it's a bit too little klino meva
civic who assumes there is what is
gaddafi via query increase  and would
make sure that longueuil at the price
practiced in africa had removed and
born infected morphée and garcia
who almost failed to communicate without a
photo boyer torture asterix but after
you know how it will be thank you
very much
we still have 14 speakers
registered and for each  p time
arole is limited to one minute and I
will strictly respect it
the first who
must exercise is our colleague luc van
den brande to welcome the fugitive to the
lists as charles welcomes and to the
clergy evp frac it's a joke or
social crisis  remained an attribution
pts he dines who is you take off is
naturist must aim for the commission that
of miss social has committed six swiss you will
sell slew of sonia and tides in
test on the coach zekri belgrade where
he lived the engine is to say city
outside  at it is voted the cabinets
of the islands this round in front of the comici
legal value instruments of edge of the
immigrants who helped it ben ali of
minimum the un is our language two
acquittals
m liquid air 1 of harry to the small ones as
to the large ones
your  problem sales digital and
artificial and intelligency we say
volcom and who is a [ __ ]
different
marc social says so bhl is essential
n will ensure the hinge active
subsidiary head complaint i  l must active
social diallo it's about four european funds
referee m frag vaart blige who is mad
with rage article is
briquettes pride homily navy 100
social europe says lure subsidiarity is
here at the local and regional anthem at  stadium
nehru not subsidiary head and i understand
steve in actors and not levy sabers
a said obama leads this joke from the sky
a deteriorates at the front goal to higuain
a leader of tactis everything is current
with him that i did not
interrupt you because  that it was your
last possibility but it is a
Christmas present that I cannot
now repeat to everyone but
this I had hoped that you were
given 10 minutes but in fact I already
thank you for it and cordially and  mercier
will have president and our flame colleague
yes because nicolas schmit united we feel
commissioners touch they slow down
and florine the taylor moms directly
an audience but history of france
it is latif the gravona commission on a
comedian as a web server created our
brothers our collective social risks in the
world steven taylor canfield october 7 and 9
guy monhée ati discs
instruments we do this job ku tokyo
dome this tour de force
writer he a face to ace monaco
dinos full this week  end to the fort the
legal commission in this area
I know that in national as tanks
marines such a fairy this one liga
this weekend and she non violence and the
great models will mix war
ricciardi of women tendido hussein we
say a big wheel  I give my faith
thank you very much the floor is our
colleague rossi on pc of intel
police station in the town and congratulations
nor on our motorcycles of agreement of cold lake
world is ok is necessary to hold a
siem and the reverse transcription as soon as
social justice  deep social
and karakistou signals no good there
will be no call for democracy a
and 1 only European unity against
the astonishing to be there regressions nor
nationalism  and populism is such that
this trio pains no name of the lobby in
monaco it seems that it is
socially uncontrolled remo that this institution
rang this 6th round hyperdense the mining
and it is a cry nati laboratory having
created 12c bleachers that will see  in the
next 12 fast transformers to
27 to the postponement of the society
that feeds in the lady is she if
she passes I recognize anyway even
if necessary and the same region to
impure ben put the laboratories and her
status minutes each between 2000 to 28  ,2
criticizing well when it pushes me to
do it founds the sheikh tamim of the
necessary training by asking me that
the reduction in the schedule of the world
elite preceded renault on sometimes farsi
carrico costumes intended for the words
are a joke because it was missing
social causes
this leads us in all models
have thank you very much the next
speakers between colleagues ball i force
and commons committee would give
industries indust  ries
thank you very much the floor is now
colleagues at guillard buenos dias by
comments guehrer of business and
associations nick fry comic talent
stuck to who our problem to
what the queen relationship problems
mps restoration bingo the region'' is
fed up with this whodunit  not castile and leon
the region of maastricht assistance in
kabrikha thursday the population of households
2 million to 6 million inhabitants you're
ugly to your relations robbins and marzio
for the fal tmp and calida weekend to
hold the radio and the control this  pole to
be ready to die before it
deserves the emotional name the
general population so that the
general health of this management despite these
red steps contract could
nickname the main brittany in skype
in regional that it is to launch
the app is described  what to
maintain satellite and the transplant of a
play the region is available the
hard sciences series not sufficiently apoyo of
the refined European plan report
elé the qualities compared
to come between robert fowler brings us out
the crayfish stacks 30 of the
migaud gorgonians claude richard politics called
for the oscars critérium perfume of european social
it's crazy cuenta at the regional abbas
so that he called the creature ngo
quynh  anh edward g and the speaking time
is rare if i give the floor to
mr beaver mr committee
clerks mr commissioner the iphone nicolas schmit when your
first union
you agreed to visit the
committee of the regions we
thus underline your interest  for towns,
cities and regions and I know your
commitment and your sympathy for the
Committee of the Regions
the commission has presented an
ambitious program with, alongside the green deal, the
issue of employment and social rights
for which you are
responsible and you  will have work
with the introduction of a minimum
wage throughout europe social cohesion
poverty security  é and
health at work and all the projects
mentioned by you, but above all it is necessary to
give prospects to young people and
give them every chance of
finding a decent job is
satisfactory I therefore congratulate you
on your idea of ​​a youth guarantee
c  is to say a commitment that all
young people under the age of 25 find a
quality offer for a job after
apprenticeship or an internship after the end
of their studies or the loss of their
job, thus breaking the circle of
poverty which risks  hitting
young people i wish you from their dear
friends the necessary energy and placed his
shot the innovative project and our
colleague peter k the cheetah commissioner
michel godin australia goss integrity
stenzel of crafting cmvm political commission
he supports the resignation of hooch
theater is that  with minister lunn in
time and at the mythical sikasso stadium thrown
a weapon or too much with the phenomenon of the
working poor orphan stadium per
year by this date  his root winningham
but barren international for duke
for all he launches production automation
the end of the smac scene and eames shuttles
to the radical and is not open to
discussions
he exists in the hands of stephen
hunt at the 2 nd costas manolas
schizophrenia trinh duke is founded  in
chesapeake had too good a tolstoy
to finance himself on this league at
the nomination ump
we hoped to win what brings back to the
tnn solidari show with what that
water heater or in the same airport
lease
like that they won't dare a name
of  the artist as well kneaded as a victim
lives below the minimums received only
films shrek 4 film whose word is
now our colleague monika
dumermuth served online weinstein
but as they say rob dyson by sharon
van damme and friborg greenberg azouvi
with kim moon  landrieu win win situation
was on board included among others nor
trace in a timely manner bilateral
as veronique thomassin food and
social takes a deep dive
be fight for game mike goodson
online committed his daughter the delegation thank you
very much the word between colleagues by
the farm of the president senior commissioner
printed loire personally congratulate
it will not answer when being a socialist
by wrongly it includes company demos did you
know power system  has been is
in rostov and which still works and
lover and in cantabria created
socialist political class ump to the european
needing a web must that the
natural population of trabajo that its
creators agree on globalization
lorik cana cambia radically telecom
for the battles of the cantons like
you're talking about cholera souika
responsible and democratic police station demography
financial policies adequate to
consult and feed the population
mental mobilization
the interconnectivity of territorial to
practices in matters of fiat to
overcome them I give the floor nor as
the instrument firminy milone of
german period
yes additionally  called may 6 in this notebook
to galati diaz to conscripts who
remain attractive according to ines capoue
american
vora feed case towards the first
rank of colectivo tour but if a
year ago will not resort collective canvas are
of course all natural or ten kirby
wii  one of its front curtains ar it is necessary to
unity dear that I you the drh of the inti
comrades betting respite from the referees of
its v8 ford to the structures life saves there
is like haiti denmark auxerre
yonne de neste with case where the icon marta
daughter marianne  to UFOs allocated to the
dark past merit said mrs hersman
racial are like regina to
technique
thank you for speaking and to our colleague
bouillon yes commissioner this
morning you did well to put
things right and then also to say that the
fight against  poverty against
precariousness is essential and must
accompany the fight against
global warming and for the
green pact I am the mother of one of
the poorest municipalities in France  with
50% social housing i know what
it is like to be poor in my city and a
lot of children don't have the
possibility to have a decent meal
so i would like to say today
how are you doing  make do with
a budget announced stagnating at 1%
to help municipalities and
communities that want to have
extremely strong action in favor of the
energy transition which also makes it possible
to transfer resources to
the poorest populations, in
particular the insulation of  buildings
in my city has made it possible to restore
purchasing power to the poorest it is necessary to
make the link between the
energy transition growth and the fight
against poverty is as
concretely as you announced a
historic plan against child poverty
that it  and make you within the
framework of the constrained budget of the
European Union thank you sir like issa for
your answer thank you very much the floor
is now with our colleague agora
specialists withdrawn close to security who
were too cheap but can't
risk and occasional to president
ribera alaïa from bus metros and ceneri
to airgas crisis and
s nests in prague his tropisms he is
put to praxy dick and nitrate sinus
and  to the point that mulberry trees syfy sea
invest herminia pole does not glimpse who on
board an experience access tickets will be
from here my screenwriter a company
after hasparren aftis tina turner
stunts madrid
what they deny this area of ​​these wsop
clint protested  this ratio to the condom
unique to our practices and friend viktor
stoian to bochum the area i can to
reviews to kin friend bruce very good
it is to their method is conducive to
masters canada the program to tokyo if
still connie the date in favor  from
the nasri corps committee which will leave this
evening in cannes at the poly energy co
program there has been more success
overdose the inoni limits at alstom
thank you the last speaker between colleagues
suddenly on president on clerk  sariat
because wade crisis new this invitation
constitutes a global systemic problem
and jean roméo leaves the geneva stadium
is a central theme
protect your limits of nioro paying
considering that conditions and bullfights
empty and insurance is available nist
counting used in 48 16 I was quickly
without dike the floor of the Julian facts
is almost combative and catchy in
10 min big points what governs
national Isérois make sense of taste and
without mediation of the six municipal agents
is finished and specific and that we
govern national to finance
ascent between that they  do not commit any of
its nokia program for the construction
of dwellings layer against watch
of ambès favorable to the commissioners who is
well or not monitor functioning of the
sector there to run diagnostics in
situ and 112 different internships members
china we are really facing the  mas nallet
prospectives
for kim proposes that the european union
provide project funding  s
of housing inflicts or creative you
generate simon ferland of brigade and
thank you very much
immediately I have it's speech
to the commissioners to answer these
many questions we are we
exactly me a month 5
it was also  at the same time parents,
it can still happen well first of all
thank you for all these
questions which are
also directly linked to the program of
this commission
so I will try to answer in
telegraphic style unfortunately but
we will have other questions
other opportunities to discuss it on
the platforms I believe that the
combat mission entrusted is to put in
place a legal social framework so that
all workers on
the platforms and the same rights as
other workers
are indeed, so this must be done in  europe
but of course we also have to
work in organizations like
the ilo and since the platforms are
often international platforms  are
global so we must also work on
an international scale but it is
not a question of Europe falling behind
since when I see that already in the
United States in California
we have adopted a law to protect in order to
better protect and working on the
platforms
anyway interesting to see that those
who invented the
platform economy now realize
that there are still some social problems
on the gender balance I believe
that this site is at the very heart of the work of
the commission
of  elsewhere madam fanta l'ariana gave
a very clear indication at the level of
the composition of the commission at the
level of the composition of the teams of
commissioners it is my colleague elena
dali who will mainly take care of this
but of course it is more  It's high
time to definitively eliminate
this wage gap between men and
women,
so we really need to
take concrete but also
binding measures so that this  gap which
still remains considerable in
terms of salaries for men and women in particular is
reduced to zero I completely agree with
what has been said on the balance on
the balance on the balance of professional life and family life
I must say the previous committee
worked a lot on this-  above, moreover,
she introduced a paternity leave
not of five days but of ten days
of ten days so we are going to continue
on this momentum and at the same time
digitalization gives us the means
to better arrange this balance but
they also constitute  dangers
since ultimately the concept of working time
becomes much more
flexible is much more difficult to
define which we must also look at
what that means in terms of
working time so that this
balance, this balance between family
life and professional life, is effectively ensured I
I agree that I haven't talked about it, but
social dialogue is key is absolutely
essential and, moreover, no
we are going to reinforce it we will
moreover just yesterday commissioner tim
ammann sa meeting and unions to
discuss a just transition the same
thing is of course also worth adding to it at
a meeting with the automotive industries of
which we  we are really going to
continue on the path of social dialogue
so an important question
and here I want to be
very clear on the legal framework in terms
of minimum wages in europe
I took I did not make a promise
I made I took a  commitment
and moreover my first trip
outside brussels
it will be to denmark and sweden
and if you understand me very well, I
am first and foremost in favor of
collective bargaining
so if we introduce a framework for the
minimum wage
we want at the same time from the perspective
of a social market economy treo
pro is not soulful to madame fanta
hatred we want to strengthen collective bargaining
and therefore where collective bargaining
works well and covers
practically all or a very large
majority of employees
we are not going to destroy it weaken it oh
there there there modified of which you have a
commitment on my part that the system which
exists in a certain number of countries and in
particular the Nordic countries that this
system will be absolutely fully
safeguarded
yes I believe that what has been said
about skills training and its
cycles and it is fundamental and Europe
must support all initiatives
also in the regions in the cities
so that skills develop  and
it is in this perspective the tail we are going to
reformulate reinforce the zanda skill which
I spoke about yes there is a problem of
development of the populations of the regions and
it is a serious problem since it is a
problem which engages the cohesion of
Europe and we cannot accept
that regions in Europe are completely
sidelined in a way
and what allows us to
reverse this situation a little
is investment in  s networks
is the development
of the economy based on
new technologies so that
young people can work
in a European economy from
their place of residence from their
region
is investment in  networks
is investment in
infrastructure and
it is investment in education and
skills
yes the problem of the minimum wage is
also an element of fighting
poverty
abah abah to arms or truth about is
specialist accepted heineken t.sap 12:10 p.m.
clown paul biya in bahrain allgemeine
the expensive have they will not have 10 comes
by lone like bergen and will not have
kenzo 10 euros panic of the hidden
nazist haufor unacceptable brownies
and long cape like bergen  town rates
politics afgans has been slack what i
made you need fauzy stars a choice
is alternating about 10m my
lot 10min sloan anything or
f1 in german cop flieg  is a
sector of comedians igadget you i
say stop room osa osa gulch offers
low israel
my son beat plead this stump
thoroughly or raw hair cdas phase i
dreamed a dream and your body painting
and victor hugo de rabat stib and
gray walls  manhattan humanist a final disc
you were born in nazareth low grade at bad
beat the shaft andaz workshops out
ibrahim cop breach 10 10 nice to meet
you goalkeeper said oft son to jo and i
owe all alone in the world
johan tracers sponeck of final sprint
yes  I know that the border regions
have a problem with telework,
it is not only my responsibility,
but it is also my responsibility in
connection with social security,
but it is also at the tax level and I
think that in a  europe where
theoretically there are more regions you have to be
easy
you are teleworking and not the
complicated where to limit it then working
within the commission means
working with all the other
commissioners and in particular  ent at the level of
regional policy at the level of
economic and social cohesion
i will work closely with
commissioner elisa ferreira since in
fact everything that is social
everything that is regional development
goes completely together
yes the budget is key the budget is
fundamental  we are not going to be able to
achieve its objectives of
combating poverty promoting training
if if the member states do not provide the
means then hop
so we have a
difficult negotiation on the framework the
financial framework and the commission and has made
proposals that I would describe
as reasonable and therefore it
is now up to the member states
to follow this reasonable path if
now they think that we can do
more politics in all the other
areas with much less means
we have to explain to us how  do
because I believe this solution
at the moment no one has yet
no one has hole yet
so we are also going to fight for
sufficient financial means so
that these objectives are achieved
my last point these housing units yes i
think it is there is a
housing crisis in europe there is a
housing crisis in europe and the housing crisis
housing is also an element of a
deeper social crisis and so
we have to with member states
with regions with cities to address
this issue and try how
through investments in
affordable housing
what is also a source of
wwa temples is  a source of growth is
something that can also help the
ecological and energy transition
copé especially at the end help
people looking for housing
I know the situations including in
the country I am from where I come from
thank you very much Commissioner
you have  was the last commissioner
we received here for a debate
during this legislature which has just gone
to years but I  I have the feeling that you
would also be among the first that the
new committee will review again
given the importance and scope of the
issues we have been talking about for the
past seven hours
thank you very much once again good
luck with your work